[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
honest trailer commentaries a bonus
episode bonus today we're talking about
the Oscars 2020 our annual whoo-ha and
what was nominated for Best Picture this
year we got a mom and bonus trailers for
you in one small video yeah and Danielle
it's deep up there we're going out with
you as a group today hopefully no
infections we're gonna respond to very
plunging to one stupid viewer comment
and we are auntie's next week's honest
trailer I guess what else is there to
talk about but the Oscars these are the
movies we did an extra trailer one of my
favorites certainly I love these be able
to do these quick punch things and
movies we'd never do when we were in a
position where we had to choose between
not doing it or having to do the extra
workload of putting on an extra one
because it's just we like doing this
much fun and I'm really excited to do
like we're having all Oscar thing again
no one seems to be with me with dressing
up I'm a dress up for Sunday you'll
state you'll shine all the more brightly
compared to us Danielle I'm having hair
and makeup I'm always bringing black
strips we're doing this all right it'll
be a glamorous night that's what she's
referring to
we'll be doing a live movie fight
immediately immediately scream
three-hour honey yeah after the telecast
is over and they've announced
moonlight as a surprise right we will be
going live with a movie fight
contestants TBD now I'm told that we are
the honest trailers specifically have
been somewhat of an Oscar curse oh I see
pointed out a few times that any movie
that we've done a full honest trailer
for prior to the awesome its nominated
for Best Picture has never won yeah we
screwed lala land we screwed revenant
like pants black pants we did after but
black panther we did before there's been
a few examples of it we did a trailer
and they were up well sorry Snow White
and the Huntsman curse is going to means
Joker would would be counted out of the
Best Picture
I hope Joker wins I love Joker stuff I
love a lot of the movies this year I
think that it's a good crop I mean I
like every single one of them that I saw
I think there are others that I liked
more this year but I'm I don't know
there's no there's not a crash among
these no groaners here I'm like no I
like there's no green right our green
green do not like it but I can I look at
that and I go okay I can see why it was
nominated there's nothing that's
baffling you know why the Academy won't
make that face together
[Music]
yeah let's not get too sidetracked we
just watch the time let's do it
Australia 2020 Oscars proceed
engage in game number one make it so I'm
gonna name every table number one from
now on it's time once again for the
Oscars the award show that everyone says
is irrelevant
until the nominations come out and
everyone gets pissed off all over again
this year's nominees for Best Picture
have a which the Academy may have even
see before they voted suppose that that
was the last at it made was the that
clip of every day I wake up we wish you
were dead we the last note was just like
can we can you Scarlett Johanson into
the Oscar statue turns into a giant
Oscar I love the notes that we give
there were if someone were to hack our
emails if someone were to Docs our
accounts you would see some of the
dumbest things things that would go in
and out because the response I remember
reading it was one of my favorite email
response as ever i'll be pulled up from
last night it was say here's our threat
kevin first of all is a rock star
yes well into the clip and the will
justice attached is the oscar trophy
edited into marriage story a lot of like
more farts you know that's another part
before let our viewers leave a beat
after the far yeah yeah no we make some
good yeah extend the foot song a lot
more feet is it possible to put this fit
after this foot yeah
can we swap this foot out for another
foot can we put this foot in front of
that but because I feel like it
undercuts it if you put that better it's
we have the fun process
now let's keep God based on a real-life
race war
wait they didn't come out right comes
the movie you'll be watching every
father's day from now until they remake
True Grit again featuring Matt Damon as
racing pioneer Carol Shelby and
Christian Bale as himself
it's candid footage yeah and for still
wondering which starts playing comported
with stars Ferrari then maybe this isn't
the movie for you here try this old
version of Mary story instead wait
they're both Kramer how that car the
supercar lamorne of justice possible
again not a best picture for me but a
fine film what are the better sports
movies if you want to call it that FC in
a while it's like Rocky if rocky where a
car yeah I enjoyed it that and rush yeah
my two favorite racing movies by default
yeah almost a while yeah I haven't seen
like actually about auto racing right uh
yeah I like it it's good yeah I was
talking too long about it and he brought
up the term that I hadn't heard before a
competence porn where it's great to look
at people who are just really good at
what they do not necessarily sports
movies like I feel like spotlight for me
was confidence porn it's like oh look at
all them working together we talked
about this and any except for the cast
Matt Damon and Christian Bale and you're
told that they're the heroes of the
story in any other movie they'd be the
bad guys cuz like Hitler like for just
like a like a monster throwing around
racial slurs and I mean it's just like
he's thing you so you should root
against these guys blank check the new
corporate conglomerate and Ferrari me
post against Italian family business
crushing them on their own turf like any
other movie we would be the bad guys
because it was made in America where
they good
all right let's get justice from the
director who won an Oscar for filming a
bag comes a perilous journey across a
world war one themed Call of Duty map
where each Czech boy is one of the UK's
hottest hogs all in a desperate race to
stop the pointless loss of 1600 men or
at least delay their deaths by about a
week Tom blowen for that's all blended
into one never-ending shot capturing the
horrors of war the chaos of battle and
the desperation of never knowing when
it's okay to go to the bathroom during
the movie and is so meticulously crafted
that much like this sentence you may not
notice that it's been one long run on
until run instead by then it could be
too late to go back to the beginning and
analyze where the places are that it was
stitched together so you'll just sit
there conscious of the fact that it's
still going until you get so used to the
fact that there still hasn't been a cut
point that you forget you were even
looking for one until the very end when
it's over and you realize that while the
patches may have been a bit obvious in
some places it's still impressive to do
something that can go on for this long
without losing its entertainment value
uncut J long winded person by nature so
it's great to give myself permission to
just write a super loss it was amazing
and also we're sorry guys we just didn't
have time it's fantastic it's definitely
best director but by a long shot
Wow it's an incredible achievement I
don't think it's my favorite movie of
the year I think it's a little bit of a
war you know it does that thing where
like the guy all the officers are like
really good at heart and you just need
just need someone to just appeal to that
humanity and they'll do the right thing
and I don't feel like that's true to
World War one in particular where like
none of them cared about these guys it
didn't it didn't feel to the spirit of
that war which is like no no okay great
yes it took one like it took one hat in
hand like stiff upper lip
okay I don't know man I'm a it was like
a lot of tears on my ass so no we hadn't
seen it before we didn't thing we do
have to acknowledge and do our
Maricopa's we knew we were gonna ban
right I'm Heights right that's right I
do feel like we had great movie I won't
be mad when it wins Best Picture I'm not
gonna be mad I know what was my favorite
movie of the year so there you go
definitely won't be made yeah not much
more to say about 1917 sad ton man well
we did we care about spoilers if you're
watching this at this point and no I do
people are like you spoil things we're
talking about the Best Picture
yeah man you should talk about the
movies the Oscars next week like what
are you there on Sunday like happen
email there are two cast members from
Game of Thrones in the movie year-old
yeah one of them is Tommen Tommen and
the other one is
mr. Rob startop Stark and also it's
Thursday because Sunday why are you
yelling at us about spoilers mm-hmm
don't watch it and don't you say WOW
when don't people yell about sports is
fine well water off a duck's back yeah
yeah all right let's keep coming Jim
he's fought the Gotham police Batman and
the Suicide Squad but on Oscar night the
Joker will face off against his most
powerful nemesis of all Martin Scorsese
in a knockdown toss to determine I'm
really bummed that there isn't a host
this year because you know they would do
it really dumb Joker answer that we
would be deprived of some what I'm gonna
call it now someone is gonna do like
Will Ferrell's gonna come out yes
Billy Crystal yeah Steve Martin so what
we're saying is someone's going to
pretend to shoot someone else yes I'm
gonna do some hilarious Joker stuff yeah
there will be someone dancing on the
stairs yeah in some sort of capacity I
was going to say I miss Billy Crystal's
montages from the beginning but then I
realize this just like youtube rewind
before all the best pictures it's like
I'm flying jack
hey you fly it oh you know like Billy
Crystal was there oh I'm very much
looking oh god I just said something
terrible
I'm very nope I'm very much nope forward
to Tina Fey big fake shot nope
effect you'll release it as a written
statement yes
guys I can't wait for me to release my
iOS press release how sorry I am
no pad app screenshot guys about how I
wanted Amy Poehler to do with him
[Music]
that premise that later one of the rare
cases where we had the double trailer or
something to say about Joker yeah but a
few times but yeah took something out of
our pants pockets yeah all right good
gone and once and for all if comic book
movies are real cinema or they're in his
words theme parks I hope not because I
do not want to take my kids to Joker
World Disorder of the Phoenix from Greta
Gerwig boyfriend comes a story about
Greta Gerwig boyfriend's ex-wife in this
thinly veiled retelling of his own
divorce only this time everyone has to
call him a genius his genius is genius
he became a genius so if you like
custody battles mom hair and amatuer dry
will removal you'll love white spouse
down pause buzz that's amazing that's
fun title hmm wow you're really trying
to know yes fired canceled right what do
you want no it's I just I get why people
have like objections but I'd please it's
a good movie please watch them oh yeah
before you have objections and then if
you have them good but please don't beat
your objections on the clip that is
clipped for the two minutes and what
twelve are two minutes and 22 seconds or
whatever that like I mean it's probably
more people saw this than most of the
other best pictures just because sadly
yeah but most of them you know yeah or
at least thirty minute they saw two
minutes of it a lot of people saw and
that's what they were like oh it's just
like watching my college theater I went
to a college theater program we weren't
that good oh there you go there you go I
thought there was a lot of acting on
screen
aggressive acts of the good sort and
yeah I just admire Noah Baumbach for
being like I'm gonna tell my story but
but man did I have a did have a big
penis like just adding money same detail
that's like like it's not me it's just a
guy who looks like me as the same
haircut as me
same profession as me but he's got a big
old shot everyone's just crazy and I'm
afraid of a genius grant that he got
genius it was crazy to just change one
detail of your life and to make it it's
hard for me because it's like legal like
like family lost [ __ ] and I'm like my
family don't want it make that family
loss a category but ya know like you
cannot like it and and feel every feel
about it but please see it first before
you well there you go first he killed
Hitler next he avenged slavery now watch
as Quentin Tarantino changes history to
say old Hollywood yay with Leonardo
DiCaprio as a washed-up star of dad
shows and Brad Pitt as the most charming
alleged wife murderer since OJ these old
chums will foil the Manson Family
killings any minute now
any minute well there he is oh no not
yet wait now we're watching TV what's
going on here
summer of 69 we used up all our
tarantino is because it's like we
already did what i'm gonna do make fun
of i did the feet for everyone to know
what our trailer just once upon a time
in hollywood would have been like that's
the yeah you know people it's like learn
the rules so you can break them like
there is not so many of these scenes in
the movie don't really do the
traditional things you ask a scene to do
of furthering the plot or revealing a
new dimension to the character there's
some new crisis but they're just so
enjoyable like i wouldn't remove a
single frame of that movie well I might
make Sharon Tate and I have dirty feet
that's one for him well just that I
really I like and I obviously like I
don't know man I'd like it said
obviously it's a fairy tale for dude
there's a dad fairy tale yeah if you go
into the movie going this is a fairy
tale for dads it's a good like don't
write tale for me I'm not a dad it's a
tale for for cinephiles of a certain age
that way and he's like but the thing age
to of a certain taste we are a certain
age we are Millennials were certain age
people who put like ascribe everything
characters do or say to the personal
opinions of the author of the director
mmm-hmm kind of throw me it's always
like what because if you know anything
about Tarantino like his main characters
in this movie they're like spaghetti
western screw that [ __ ] that's Europeans
like there's nobody on earth who could
be a bigger fan of those types of movies
than Quentin Tarantino yeah but Sergio
Leone in them like Oh Tarantino why you
do this but some of them in this movie
it's like him and of course the white
dude beats up Bruce Lee like that's a
dude fairytales like what he does yeah
the movie is yeah yeah like why it's
also it's a movie he didn't actually
beat up Bruce Lee it's okay okay
he Bruce Lee never lost a fight - I mean
if you want to respect Bruce Lee's
daughter watch WM AC Masters on wherever
you can find it and then send me a thing
immediately well I enjoyed it I think I
liked the movie a lot I think it's it's
a series of really when I cracked it
watching it the first time it's a series
of setups and payoffs yes in succession
instead of one overarching thing it's
sort of these little sequences that
gradually build toward the end and I
quite enjoy it yeah it's very pretty but
I am a man of a certain taste let's give
our certain age or whatever it's been
adapted four times for theater stages
points
[Music]
we gotta watch this next year a book you
were signed in high school that you
flipped around to the important bits to
cram for an essay in this classic tale
of four little women and the even
littler boy who's working his way
through them one at a time dance and the
final message for girls you don't have
to choose between marriage family and
career as long as a distant relative
dies and leaves you a massive fortune
oh and marry a hot doctor anyway
couldn't hurt yeah I love this movie I'm
such a Search Search ahead what do we
call ourselves No yes sir certian
searching for I don't know you tell us
what we're calm but she was fantastic in
this movie I loved her in Brooklyn I've
seen Little Women in one form or another
a million times and I was like oh god
not again but I thought that they had
enough they put enough jaj on it and
made it new and oh the directing was
great
it's I know it's Little Women but yeah
are you a Joe or a Meg trying to find I
couldn't find I'm sorry the yearbook
picture of me is Joe oh nice that would
have been great yeah I think really what
do we think about Salome
rise as the prettiest boy in school I
mean he's a wonderful actor he nearly is
a phenomenal actor I and I said this is
where Ross and I reviewed the movie I'm
a little bit tired of seeing him is like
the waifus sad boy no just because I've
seen him now and that several roles is
the sort of way fish sad boy and and
he's wonderful he's wonderful playing
that but I also looking forward to dune
is what I was yeah we could use fewer
characters of his that like Liam
pensively against a windowsill yeah but
back then like that was high that was
the good hotness and now there's like a
new Emma and I'm like didn't we already
cover that with clueless but I will
watch it yes Emma Paltrow it's so cool
it's fine I bet it's amazing and it's
really good yeah well I think so he
should follow the the Leo playbook right
cuz he's to me this is like leo he
doesn't have his Titanic yet I doubt
that will be dune but like he's doing
he's got his Romeo and Juliet and his
Basketball Diaries now so he's got to do
the big franchise what's his tight end
yeah but they don't make Titanic so any
more writing they do but the superhero
role like what is it that makes him
please no I mean if it's a musical if he
could go back in time you could probably
be the flash and that would have been as
Titanic potentially but I don't know
good question I think that's the career
blueprint for fancy boys yeah and
aspiring fancy boys and then he goes to
work with clinics seriously crazy yeah
what is it he should remake the berries
and cream berries and cream I'm sorry
yeah all right what do you think she'll
ma should do next let's get going plucky
young racist Jo Jo rabbit loves two
things the promise of a thousand-year
Reich and to dance
but he's not alone meet his pal Sam
Rockwell's and rebel Wilson who put the
CNY in na Zi hey guys featuring double
Oscar nominee Scarlett Johansson Wow how
does she do that
it's gotta be the shoes restoring
hangover as you've never seen it before
hilarious movie Final Solution Boy Meets
World War 2 this wasn't actually Hitler
either it was a child's idealized
version of yeah
also Sam Rockwell you don't have to be
racist sorry we spoiled it for people
that's kind of the people that were
angry about us playing spoiled rabbit in
that movie we're the ones who had
already seen the movie the people
yelling us for spoilers about a movie
that they've already seen on behalf of
people who haven't seen the movie who
evidence probably wouldn't have noticed
it there's a spoiler and that is it you
you played yourself you played yourself
a reference
all right let's get going get ready for
a Korean film about class and you to
stop listening look you only have to
watch one foreign film a year okay so
put on your glasses and strap it in as a
struggling family cons they're way above
the poverty line while working for the
worst kinds of rich people rich people
House Hunters International buzz the
thing that we didn't find a way to work
in that I thought was a good observation
is why is that toilet up so high
what's so high is it no looking back at
it it's like oh is it so that they can
crack that window was that it I don't
why would you have such an elevated
toilet here's what here's what I think
they live underground yes so I think
maybe the plumbing depressed floors the
toilet is high because that's where the
pipes go below the ground
Wow thank you for cracking that case I
mean that's my guess I don't know gross
stuff there's great Thursday sorry
there's really good green screens behind
the big house the the oh gosh I wish I
knew the name of the Twitter account
that talked about it showed like the
before and after of like the way that
they they're CGI you know yes I think it
won't but I think it should when best
production design okay because well
because it's seamless and people just
take when it's a normal location people
just take it for granted and they're
like oh that was that was just there but
I think it's true invest production is
so gorgeous well there you go
great yeah and check out um we'll do
more cross promotion I think it's
lessons from the screenplay did a video
about montages and how this movie uses
them the montage of like the basically
the poisoning of the housekeeper and
with the like peaches and Heather it's
going back and fro and the plan and
executing it and not great film yes
sweet good job good
nerdwriter sorry yeah so yeah watch that
movie well there you go let's get go
prepare for a master class from actors
Robert De Niro Joe Pesci Al Pacino and
their creepy the aged avatars for an
epic saga I never got a relationship
between the Teamsters Union and
organized crime that you're still
working your way through because you
hear good things about The Witcher and
they just dropped a new season of
Terrace house
what's the circles it looks like fine
I'm sure the second half of the movie is
just as good as the first half let's
just assume it all ends well for
everyone didn't even make it back to
Ireland that'd be nice right add to my
watch list what more is there to say
it's fun fun take on a on a movie that
like we could try to pick that movie
apart but what are you gonna say yes
So Solid is my thing with parasite
where's like how do I taking a party
yeah yeah well that's that's what's good
about this is we always say how hard it
is to do good movies like it's hard to
do a four-minute on this trailer but I
think we've got 30 seconds of good
material on just about anything yeah we
got it one good joke about anything we
have good joke about most we put all of
our minds to 30 to 45 seconds of
material that's your honesty
that is my metric sadly when I go back
and watch early ones I'm like if I laugh
once that's the words like okay
starring the biggest trends in best
pictures this year
inappropriate laughter that's funny
class divides hidden rooms cowboys and
Indians what are you burning what are
you burning precocious kid seems he's a
genius you know I mean a once in over
fifty or hundred years kind of cheese
what are you 12
I know we're to release dates getting to
a meeting on time what
and it was traffic the second are due to
attack the line shortly after dawn
tomorrow you think you can get there in
time Charlie finally arrived two hours
late to pick up Henry at Nicole's
mother's house I was waiting for you how
was that two o'clock is supposed to
shout cheering actors
and white people dancing
so if we were gonna make an Oscar
contender it'd be about a dancing white
person trying to get to a Pina Garden
tonight starring Robert De Niro Scarlett
Johansson and a precocious story
following completely I would like to say
read this text very closely
yeah the following come completely
snubbed film night continued tenure yes
he snubbed films that deserved it in
some kind of recognition alongside these
nine
[Music]
thank you thank you
director you should put director fred
durst eos 2020 if Joker's up for 11
awards they'll have to show at least 11
clips of it oh no this is a worldwide
broadcast what if people realize they
live in a society there you go I guess
if we have any deleted anything let's
let's play it now then we'll review will
respond to viewer comment mm-hmm World
War one shots by the way this is a
choice to be West Coast Avengers logic
acts couples retreat marriage door we
[Laughter]
Manson Family Values my favorite almost
murderers Manson family cookout I never
kills enter it the daughter
Oh silly fix you need to make all these
again nutty party down super bad
no really super bad like the worst
the Indian in the cupboard eat the rich
people's food the people under the
stairs lights
billions of peaches peaches for ya long
chute mostly terrible fellas not married
to the mob at the age of innocence old
to look your labor pains that
recommended for you popular on Netflix
there it is there we go we have one more
no no yeah well there you go we're not
good at pairing things down no not the
best we just one of those Jojo rabbit
ones yeah it's a lot yeah yeah I'm sorry
Roberts night Rob we had a lot of
comments but only one was repeated and
insufferable which was this I'm gonna do
my worst of always this is like you
sound like comment exactly what you
sound like
and we said completely snubbed it got an
Oscar nomination for Best Cinematography
slow your roll catch up on our Oscars
video we put it up for a bunch of stuff
like like like we don't respect a good
light house how dare you
we respect to light house yeah respect a
fart enlightened housekeepers
and this has been respective ardently
respect from my lighthouse keeper
nothing but respect exactly alright yeah
them's the Oscar movies this year the
Oscars I can't wait to do it again this
is like you said super fun we couldn't
let it pass us by
no we doing it next week is a film that
we could let pass by but I'm sure and
come back again soon oh yeah it'll be
back nice all right we'll see you then
and will maybe see before then this
weekend Sunday Night Live movie fights
after the Oscars thanks for watching bye
bye
[Music]
you